I don’t know about you, but when I’m washing
my face I prefer to use some exfoliating scrub.
You know the kind with little beads to make
your face feel squeaky clean.
But those beads go somewhere after they’re
washed down the drain.
And it’s not good!!
Hey guys, Julia here for DNews
Microbeads feel great.
I mean my face just feels like a million bucks
after I give it a good scrub.
Those tiny plastic beads are found in other
products like soap and even toothpaste.
But those beads wind up in the environment
after we’re done with them and could do
some serious damage.
And while a lot of plastic in the ocean comes
from food products like plastic wrap and bottle
caps, a lot of it is from these small microbeads.
A recent study published in the journal Marine
Pollution Bulletin found if millions of these
beads get released into the water, the researchers
estimate this could result in up to 80 tonnes
of unnecessary microplastic waste.
Because they’re small and buoyant, they
easily pass through sewage treatment plants.
Basically that’s eight trillion microbeads
entering oceans and lakes every day.
According to a study published in the journal
Environmental Science & Technology.
And that’s just the beads that make it past
the filters at the treatment plants.
Those that don’t make it through wind up
packed in with sludge.
The very nasty mix of waste that’s filtered
out of waste water.
It’s often used as…
I hope you aren’t eating.
But it’s often used as fertilizer.
So it’s spread across fields.
And nearly 800 trillion of those tiny beads
are all trapped in it.
And from there some of the microbeads get
caught up in run off and well..
And usually they wind up in someone’s stomach.
And that’s bad news.
A study published in the journal Global Change
Biology found that half of the ocean’s turtles
ingest plastic.
Another study published in the Proceedings
of the National Academy of Sciences found
that 90% of seabirds have plastic in their
stomachs, up from just 10% 30 years ago.
Some researchers think that fish might mistake
the beads for food, eat them, then mistakenly
think they’re full.
Not to mention that plastic can poison the
animals or lead to blockages in their intestines,
both potentially deadly!
And the microbeads and other microplastics
can make things even worse, despite their
size they can concentrate toxic chemicals
already present in seawater.
Basically they act like little sponges that
soak up toxins which can accumulate in sea
life and maybe be passed on to people.
It’s not just microbeads, they’re only
a piece of a much larger problem.
Researchers say there are 360,000 pieces of
plastic for every square mile in most of the
world's oceans.
Another study published in the journal Science
found that as many as 12.7 million metric
tons of plastic find their way into the ocean
every year.
The most striking result of all this plastic
pollution are giant trash gyres circling on
the surface of oceans.
And when I say giant I mean GIANT.
The most infamous of which is the Great Pacific
Garbage Patch.
It’s estimated to be twice the size of Texas
or some estimates say it’s even the size
of the US.
Plastic doesn’t biodegrade, instead, things
like microbeads or plastic bottles simply
break into smaller and smaller pieces.
Most of the Pacific Garbage Patch is made
up of tiny pieces of plastic, so you could
be standing on a boat and it looks nothing
like a landfill.
Instead, these tiny pieces float right below
the surface, making the water muddy and unclear.
And all this microscopic plastic is doing
some real damage to the inhabitants of those
waters.
So what do we do?
Well already there’s legislation proposed
the “Microbead-Free Waters Act of 2015”
was introduced to the house earlier this year.
The aim of the bill is to ban cosmetics that
contain synthetic plastic microbeads beginning
on January 1, 2018.
And even if the legislation doesn’t go through,
some companies have agreed to replace them
with more natural products.
But even if we could ban microbeads, it still
leaves a lot of plastic floating around.
So researchers recommend “industrialized
countries can take immediate action by reducing
waste and curbing the growth of single-use
plastic."
Basically, you know the drill, reduce, reuse
and recycle.
And stop using those face scrubs.
Also if you think biodegradable plastic might
be the answer to our problems, think again
- here’s a video from Trace explaining more.